and
The gaming screen, go to the gaming screen, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I got it, yeah.
Hello!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hello.
We made it on.
It's okay if you can hear them and me properly.
We avoided the curse of the streamers and actually booted up the game we wanted to.
Christmas weekend round of applause.
Round of applause everyone.
It actually worked.
Christmas weekend.
I'm the volume everyone.
Please tell me how is the volume?
How is everyone?
How does everyone sound?
Hello.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Let's go first.
EP.
Volume good.
Yes.
Some of the girls.
Volume.
Oh my God.
I have volume.
Why are you 150?
I had to turn you down.
Holy shit.
Finally done it.
Wait for who donated that.
Who is anonymous?
Anonymous 100.
Thank you anonymous.
We love you.
Wow.
Thanks Mr. Anonymous.
Okay.
Should I start the game?
Does anyone want?
Do you want more strokes?
Do you want more?
I would love more strokes.
Who wants to?
What's the auto scoreboard?
Mad bitch.
What's the collision?
Yeah.
The collision will be funny.
Okay.
What is collision?
Wait, wait, what is collision?
We can hit each other.
We can hit each other's balls.
Oh my God.
Did you guys customize your balls?
No.
Oh.
No?
How do you do that?
How do I customize my balls?
I can customize my balls?
Yeah.
It's on the main screen.
You guys didn't customize your balls?
Help left sit.
Oh my gosh.
I can customize my ball.
Thank you.
Give me a second.
What's situm?
SDMM.
I thought you said SDD.
It's in top left.
Customized ball.
And it's put SDMM on situm.
So cute.
I have a flaming hot ball.
Okay.
Now my ball has hearts.
How do you customize the ball?
There's one with X's in me.
There is where?
Oh, I see it.
You can customize my ball.
That's my ball.
Everyone's so excited to have their own custom ball.
Oh my God.
That's amazing.
All right.
Beautiful.
You can customize your balls.
I'm almost done.
I need to like radio.
You can put a hat on your ball.
Am I ready?
I can't tell if I'm ready or if I'm not ready.
I don't know if green or yellow is ready.
Green, green is ready.
Oh, okay.
I'm ready.
Azura, are you ready?
What's your name?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Well, wait.
I don't think she is.
Yeah.
I don't think she's.
That's like.
Well, oh, not every player is ready.
Not every player is ready.
Already done.
I need a ready.
Oh, I'm going to press the button.
Yes.
Yes!
Oh, hell yeah.
Hell yeah.
Oh, god.
Oh, no.
Hey, yo.
How do we play?
How do I play?
What button do I press?
Oh, what is happening?
Wait, what happened?
How did I?
How do I do this?
Hello?
Huh?
This is so weird.
Um.
Oh, I'm so close.
I don't know how to do this.
Wait, I don't know how to do it either.
How do you?
Aim.
Click.
And then click.
Oh, this is great.
Oh.
This is so cool.
Oh, shit.
Oh, click in your ass.
Hi.
I'm bogey.
I don't know.
She's just so cute.
You got to pull it back early pop.
Zura will say thank you once the collab's over.
But thank you, everyone, for supporting this.
Zura, we really appreciate you having me there.
Uh-huh.
We love you.
Ignore me.
I think I know it's like a long road.
You know it's like a long road.
We're in the road.
It cannot give up.
Oh my god.
I'm not flesh.
Yes.
Broke.
What broke?
What?
That was trash.
No way.
The TTS broke.
Oh, fuck it.
We off the fucking thing.
I'm still struggling to figure out how to play right now.
You got this little sis.
Yeah, there you go.
No, not the double boogie.
The double what?
The boogie.
The boogie, of course.
The double boogie.
The boogie.
Oh, shit.
The boogie is...
Where's the hole?
In the ass.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
Hit it again slow.
Damn, everyone got a hole in one.
Let's go.
Oh.
I thought I was going to be the only one that didn't get it and I was going to cry.
Everyone's anonymous.
Come on, fuck.
Wait, all the donations are anonymous?
Yeah.
Thank you.
No, no, no, no.
I'm trying to learn how to do this.
This is hard.
It is hard.
Fuck.
But I'm harder.
No Mary.
I think Mary said her love heart is coming off of her.
No, I didn't mean to do that.
Damien, you guys are struggling on this.
Here we go.
I am terrible at this.
Please.
Oh my god.
Triple boogie, that's fine.
We didn't play a practice run, to be honest.
We're just going to do it only.
We just went all seven strokes for different folks.
Oh my god.
Where is the hole?
Oh, shit.
Fuck.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Anonymous.
Oh, frick.
Hold on.
It is really dark in this one.
I see, why are you on my back side right now?
I want to.
I do what I want.
I can't see.
I'll get the action show.
Am I just gonna golf?
Oh, shit.
What gamer?
Golf, golf, golf, golf.
No way.
Edging, edging, edging.
Edging the rim.
I'm so mad.
Oh my god.
All right, here we go.
We got to do...
Oh, I did it.
Where the fuck I am?
Come on.
Okay, hold on.
These are actually kind of easy.
I missed the hole.
What the hell?
I'm still sleeping.
Why?
Oh, you guys are new.
Who was that?
It was Zara.
Fuck this shit.
Me and Mercy are struggling over here.
I can tell.
I'm glad. I'm finally not the one
struggling in the game.
I'm in my life.
I'll thank you.
Shut up.
Toxic golf.
You know what, me and Mercy,
we're fine on the bottom.
We'll lift everybody up.
I don't want to be on the bottom.
I want to be on top.
Where's the hole?
Well, you can come off this map.
Can I jump?
I don't know.
You can come off this map.
Okay, right, enough.
That's three strokes. I keep trolling.
I'm trolling.
Come on.
Fuck. Damn.
Am I going to roll all the way back?
No!
What?
Stay, stay, stay, stay.
Oh, my God. I'm going to permit.
You're shooting me right now!
I'm throwing.
Guys, guys, what the hell is this?
This is no fun.
I'm going to make it.
$100!
I'm throwing. I'm going to throw.
No, no, no, no.
I'm going to cry. Where am I?
Hello?
What the fuck am I supposed to say?
No!
I killed AC.
I'm creeping. I'm on the edge of glory.
What the fuck is this?
I'm going to live in the room.
Who picked the main step?
What am I doing?
Of course.
Shawty.
Shawty with the salt.
I hate it.
Is there a maximum amount?
There has to be a maximum amount.
It's 12 strokes.
Well, it can be, because I've managed to...
My battle is 12.
I guess it's not.
Shortened behavior.
Almost whole in one.
That was...
I needed to even the playing field.
Oh, okay.
I'm sorry, I swore.
How dare you swear?
I can't believe you, Mercy.
How could you swear?
I'm so fucking stupid.
I got the trick shot.
Sorry, I said such bad words.
I will remember to fuck myself.
You're gonna fuck yourself?
I can't believe you're going to fuck yourself.
Are you winning?
What the fuck is the salt thing?
It's me.
I put salt on myself.
It's like one-on-one.
Didn't you know golf started in Scotland?
To have like a racial passive to this.
I'm not even kidding.
Stop, stop, stop.
Please, please, please.
Oh, thank god.
We have thrown in that 17.
No, on my screen.
I see the bottom.
For all your 12 strokes.
What was that?
Oh, you're supposed to go in the middle.
Let's go.
Strawny, get out of my face.
Strawny, follow me up.
I was doing so good.
What the fuck?
Fuck this.
Are you reaching over golf right now?
Yes.
Because I always fucking suck at games.
Give me a game.
Give me a second.
I got a spammer in chat.
Damn.
What are they saying?
Monkey.
I'm gonna fart on him.
We're farting on him.
Shitin on him.
Shibin and Fartin.
Fartin on him.
I'm tired because I blocked that.
Motherfucker.
You're tired?
What? That was like a pro strat.
Hold on.
What the hell?
Hello?
Damn it.
Where's the hole?
Where?
It's like through the yellow tunnel.
I found it.
I keep on getting the...
So mad.
That was gonna be A plus plus.
Why do I have to be behind whatever the fuck this is?
What does bogey mean?
Bogey?
Bogey is three.
I'm being hit.
I'm gonna start choosing violence.
I'm gonna start targeting others.
Don't sabotage us.
Wait, they're moving?
The goal is moving.
No fucking way.
What the hell?
We gotta time it.
We need to pick the easy peasy levels.
What is this?
I'm sorry.
Where am I?
There's no way we're supposed to just...
What the fuck is this?
Wait, I don't know.
How are you supposed to...
I'm sorry.
I missed something.
How am I supposed to fucking do this?
Hi, Amy.
I'm begging.
Let me come a little bit closer.
Shit.
I did it before I came.
I got this.
Bad timing. It's okay.
Okay, we're still here.
We're still here.
I'm going too gently.
I don't think he's still alive.
I'm sorry.
I'm so close.
No!
Wait, that actually almost helped me.
Come on.
Let me go.
Let me go first.
Shit! I'm sorry.
Fuck this shit.
This one's really hard.
What the hell was that, Amy?
I did it!
Wait, did anyone get in the hole?
Damn.
I'm throwing myself on the train tracks, for real.
I was literally...
I'm about to end it all.
Why is this so hard?
Fuck that!
Azura did it.
I did it in the hole.
Okay, I'm going to come a little bit closer.
I don't think this is happening.
No, wait! How did I not get in the hole?
You did get it.
You did get it, Mercy.
You got it, Mercy.
Oh, I got it.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 25, Mr. Anonymous.
Why did I get penalized 17?
No one else got penalized 17.
Why would you say it like that?
Penalized?
What did you say?
Penalized.
Where's the thing?
All the way over there.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, how do you say penis
and how do you spell penalized?
P-E-N-I
P...
Penalized?
Okay, I'm watching.
I don't know how to spell it.
Listen to me.
Where's the goal?
In the hole.
The fucking tree!
What am I hitting?
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
Wait, any of these is the goal?
I wish I could have just said
that I've never played this game before.
Please, Johnny, how do you say pen?
Please.
Pen.
Penalized.
Please, for the love of God.
These things.
These main show.
Oh, these are for the love of the holy goddess Azura.
That was far too hard.
Oh, God.
Which one is the hole?
Are they all the holes?
My hole.
Oh, wait, the one with the flag.
Oh, wait.
How am I supposed to...
I'm glad I'm not the one struggling.
I'm still at the fucking start.
Hell yeah.
I'm still at the start too.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I did it. I did it. I made it.
I made that. All right, let's go.
Now I just realized I forgot
to turn off this.
What?
What? Are you done?
What have you done?
Nothing. So they didn't do anything.
Did you have your background music on?
No.
Mine is. I saw my background music on.
There was.
Okay, all right.
Where is it?
It's the same place as before.
Who hit me?
I'm going this way. I'm following in me.
Spanked it rather gently that time.
Do apologize.
Let's try that a bit harder.
Oh, all right.
I'm on X games.
So is Emmy.
No!
Stay, stay, stay.
Hey.
That was so funny.
Son of a...
Double bogey.
Bye.
Someone literally goes to my stream.
I switch streams just to say it's
Penalize.
What the fuck happened?
What are you doing?
Fuck!
I'm about to die in money.
Frozen?
No, I killed Icy.
I see like...
Glitching for me.
Let's go home.
What the fuck?
What is this?
You guys suck at golf.
I will shove those golf balls
in your mouth and ass.
I'm telling you amazing.
Azura is doing good.
If I make girl look clearly...
How do we get over to this one?
It's always a good game.
We've all seen it multiple times.
Yeah, Azura is just nothing fucking new.
This is her comeuppance.
This is the way for me.
I did not hit her.
Okay, that was a bit too hard.
I was so close.
What?
I have to be back all the way over here.
Are you kidding me right now?
Fucking shit.
Please stop.
We'll play the beginner map.
I didn't know there was beginner maps
and hard maps.
Golf with friends?
Enemies.
Battle over y'all?
Golf?
Alright, here we go, folks.
Here you go.
Here's a bunch of nothing.
Girl, girl, girl.
Wait, I also got monkey spam.
You also got monkey spam?
What the hell?
Chongo, what are you doing, brother?
Don't even say their name.
They love attention.
I wish I had mods. That'd be great.
Same.
I think everyone's mods are not used to this time.
They're like asleep right now.
I remember.
Yeah, thank you for
membering.
Azura.
Thank you for the member.
What was his name again?
We can all celebrate his name.
Azura.
For the member?
Yeah.
I'm now recovering from this.
There's no recovery.
Because of golf.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Siegfried?
I don't know. I'm just guessing.
Thank you, Mr. Siegfried.
Thank you, Mr. Sigma.
Sigma nuts.
It's so good.
Actually, I was wondering,
did you guys ever go to Saucon with me?
Saucon with you?
Yeah, Saucon.
I'm so happy I didn't fall.
I was about to say.
I was going to warn you guys.
I was like, no, let them fall, man.
Where's my phone?
At least they don't know about Madder Daddy's.
That's all I'm saying.
That's another one.
What is Madder Daddy's?
How about you, baby girl?
No, let's just say Madder Baby.
Would you rather eat
a baby ghoul or a Madder Baby?
What's Madder Baby's?
I know this one.
I don't know.
Did you already go?
Oh, wait.
We're all waiting for you.
I didn't know this will grow.
I was laughing too hard.
Thank you Grim by B.E.V.E.L.R.
for the 10 gifted membership.
Grim by B.E.V.E.L.R.
Thank you.
So slow for me.
Are you okay?
Why is my bowl not blue?
Why is it white?
Why?
You can't just ask that.
You can't ask why guys have blue bowls.
Yeah.
Where's the hole?
No, X is not the hole.
X is not the hole.
I don't think so.
Oh, that's not it.
Are they fake holes?
They might be fake holes.
Fake holes, fake holes.
Can I clip through and see where this leads to?
Why did he do it?
I don't know.
Surprise.
Are you kidding me? How did it not fall in?
I don't get that.
Why am I supposed to get there?
Don't tell him.
Don't tell her. She'll figure it out.
You got this, Trani.
You're so close.
You're so close, Trani.
Trani, you're so close.
You're so close.
Wait, no, Trani, it's definitely the one behind you.
Information's on the way.
It's the one you're right next to right now, Trani.
It's that one.
On the left, on the left.
On the left.
You're right.
Oh
If I got that in hole in one I would have literally just like
So good
Can I stop bouncing for the love of God
Okay, that was far too hard
Where am I?
Okay, this one's hard. I know the power. I have the power
I literally just got in how did I not get
Did you just see me I just made it in I just made it in and they kicked me back same
Shit me right meow
Ronnie just get in I finally got in
Oh my god
I got a shell. Oh my god, I got witches up. What's up? Oh my god
I need to be invited again. I'm sorry. I didn't
That's okay. That's okay. I'll invite you. Um, I rage quit. I'm so sorry. It's okay. You're so real for that
So real for that
Oh
And then you get
I forgot to use everyone's cold
What fucking cold for gamers
Oh
Wait, did somebody do what I did what did you do?
Nothing never mind
Avoid if we uh
We never did it. Oh, I never did anything
Is there are you ready? This reminds me of what what what took place to see our our our lovely
Super bunny mandate
I've been chilling gamers up so hard
Guess what I'm drinking
I'm forever drinking lean. I'm sorry. I really like lean lean is good
Man, I wish I had the caffeine one of lean. I need to buy that
I want to lean
Bidin on it now it doesn't well it does but he's wearing a mustache or glasses
You're in the game
Oh, look, we are playing golf in my home. Let's find
Wow, and I'm doing fucking terrible
Is it more slippery because it's icy
You go on go on then story go on
Otherwise I'm gonna
That's why you want to slip on the ace hole slip on these slides
I'm gonna achievement hit the ball
No one's special but actually special to me
She's very special too. AC has home advantage. What the heck?
Let's fucking go
Like why can't I control the camera?
I think you can
It's the scroll wheel
All right, you're your azure your mic's cotton. I think because you're so happy if I turn around and go back to the hole that we
Went to before does that count?
I'm tweaking. I'm tweaking. That's so fun. I think it would count. I think it's three five hundred
Three five hundred
Let's go
Thank you
You better hire that moving truck like today
Over the names after the club, I promise she'll she'll she'll do it. She'll do it. I'll make her do it
That's very sweet
Oh
Oh my gosh, you are doing fantastic, sweetie. You deserve this
100%
Is there a love? I'm just getting you out of that house. I'm spamming it
I'm just gonna fucking sit. Don't don't meet me mods. Don't meet me
Oh
Go send her some love guys go send her some
Okay, we have advantage now that azure fucked up that last one because she's so happy
We've got the good ending we've got the good end. That's right
Keep supporting us so we can win because she wins everything. She wins everything we play real. Let's go. Oh, no
I'm trying so hard
Geography
I can't see
It's okay our advantage
For once in my life, thank you. Why am I on top of scrawny?
Yeah, you like that and why am I on top of azura? What's happening? I'm floating in midair
Is your ping high? No, your ping can't be high. My ping is what I my internet is dying right now
Where's the where's the hole?
What's an ac's bowl will fly in and then hearing
Fucking hit it
Why does it say I have five strokes?
I don't understand that. I never really a hell yeah hell yeah
What the hell
Oh
Kitcha oh damn
Oh, can I live in another turn? Yeah, I'm not even kidding
Dear me
Oh
Ac's ac is so hard
Please
My
I can't do this one
I literally can't do this one
I believe in my little sister I don't care what I got
I'll hold over there. No my internet
It was me you're welcome. Thank you. I see
Please don't hit me off. I will cry
I appreciate that. I just stay where I am because people will just hit me
Shouldn't you right now? I'm stuck on a rock
Where are you?
Can you not move
Oh
Let's go saved
So it's an impromptu karaoke team. Oh that was almost a move. That was a good one
Nice. Sorry. I got stuck
30 seconds left. I'm very online
She made it
Shit
Are happening right now
There's some nice music
Oh, no, we are kidded into
Oh, thank you. No
Anytime happy to oblige. Nice job
Are you kidding me right now?
Hard baby
I see
There's a hole at okay, she's behind us
Okay, that was a bit too aggressive. That's fine
All right, lower that test officer
Gamer move
I wish this was a game mechanic. Fuck this
So true
My mouse is freaking out as well
Squeak squeak I need to get a new mouse my mouse double clicks like I'm getting extra strokes. That's useful is it for some games
I can't I see as strongy
Oh sisters wedding
He's getting married to emmy
I'm a good girl. He's getting married
Oh my god, fuck we're got this you can jump in golf with friends. So I'm disappointed. This isn't that and
Is it in this game? Okay
There's my boy. I'm familiar with this game. I'm actually not familiar with golf with friends. Should we it's the opposite for me
I'm familiar with golf with friends, but this is my first template in golf. Yeah, same
Please make me make
Let's go
Suck my motherfucking strap
Okay, and thank you. I hate this
Oh my god
Normally she makes the other screams so it's quite nice to be on the the receiving end of her screams
Oh
I'm on x games. Oh that didn't work. I'm on x games
Oh, that kind of work. All right. All right. All right. All right. Stay with strat. Oh, thanks. Thank fucking god. Let's go
Too hard
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I just want to find you. Oh, thanks. Oh
Don't go too far. Don't go too far, bitch
Okay, I'll come
I'll come
Yeah, I keep going into the same weak corner
Last long
I'm coming up. I'm coming up. I'm coming up. See this bacon. You better get the party started. Yeah, come on. What do you think about?
mainly
You're gonna spawn golf and at least make your
Hey, I'm in first for the first time
Oh my god, why was it because
Oh
What the shibbity wait wait, I can take this to my advantage. What the shigma?
Oh, you're gonna put that in my head. You're gonna regret that. I'll cut it in a word.
The music is so calm considering how chaotic we are communicating.
Then the pianist was like
Hmm
I'm blowing it. I'm blowing my lead
I hate I hate video game and I hate gaming and I hate
I didn't bring anyone in anything. All right, I'm innocent
I'm going backwards. No one is innocent
If everyone wants to pick I'll take responsibility for picking this one
I thought this was the main one apparently is golf it with friends, but I've never played golf it with friends
Guys, I literally
I originally thought it was golf with friends. Are we allowed to tell the story? Is there a?
Yeah
So Emmy hosts the lobby and we're all joining and is there is like it's just no letting me in
And we're like, okay, that's strange. Okay. Well, you know what? We've got enough time. We'll go buy golf with friends
And she's like golf with friends
Yeah, go from friends because we're on golf right now. What? You never told me that
Who's it really funny funny? She's like, I'll need to use on the wrong game. It was so cute
I'm me. I'm
Thanks
I will wait I will wait patiently
How do we get in there? Oh wait never mind. Oh, I'll take it. I'll take it. I can't pull it one
Surely this is
Can I do that? I can't. I thought I did something
And I did nothing. You know what? See my ancestors big William Wallace. I call upon me. What the fuck are you doing?
Come on
I'm actually
One round of golf it before we have to pop off
I'm already popping off
Where's the where's the hole?
Oh
I can't pronounce where
Someone did 650 is there? Can you see that?
question
I'm on the edge of
I know
Frost I know
I don't know how I got Bastardo from Frosty. I'm gonna be honest
You're on a different one
That's the last level
Go down gently the hole is just below you
Yes, yes, yes
Yes, perfect. There's a hole
A little 180. Look at it. Look at it. Like uh going in and out
Oh, I saw my score was 69. Oh my god. It's anonymous
Collision there's solutions from Momotou. Thank you. Thank you. Momotou anonymous. We love you
I love you. Okay. I'm gonna let them all collate ahead because I know I'm I'm just
You don't want to kiss me, but come on
All right roll and I hate this
The ace is killing me
I love getting beat up by you
We your balls are spanked together
Oh, what the heck?
How am I going backwards?
Where's Trani?
Trani, you're going the wrong way
Wait, why is it and I'm getting pushed forward
It's the ice ice ice baby
Oh my god, I'm gonna can't wait to take the first spot
From strongy because of this
I need to possess by Robert the Bruce right now. I'm gonna teach you a little bit about scottish history
All right, big Robert the Bruce eye. He said english
No, you're not having this land and why is he not possess me right now? Because what's going on?
No idea
And you all have to sit in it his name is Robert the Bruce big willy wallace big mary queen of scots
I'll teach. Oh my god. I see weapons. We spanked
Mercy you can go first
There's a moolong song that goes like ancestors hear my plane
I'll bring honor to Scotland
The azura goal on our screen right now says azura sus audio roleplay
We couldn't actually put what the content of that roleplay is on the
Where's the whole maybe fall? Oh, it's behind us. Oh my god. Thank you. Did I get oh
Oh
Fucking
Not bad not bad
Oh, dammit
Oh, dang it. Let's go golfing. Oh, dang it. Oh, dang it. Come on, dang it
Well, I love ac's like frustration screams
Because they're cute. I'm like mine. They're like, you know, like a pterodactyl
It does sound like a pterodactyl
Doesn't pick it up
Oh
Oh, fuck me, bro, okay
I've got a bone to pick with me. Hold on a minute. Where tweet gave me a heart attack
That's because it didn't just play fully
It didn't just play fully. So the first thing is I'm leaving viola and I'm like
At least let me hit the three months anniversary before someone goes
please
Sorry
Oh
No, I've not won yet. It's not over until it's over. You know what I'm saying? It's not over yet. Oh, what the hell
All right, this is a weird one
No, what
How do they do worse on the second pot than the first one?
Are you in
I'm watching her stream right now. I'm opening up her stream. I want to see
I got it. Okay. Okay. Okay. Stay stay stay stay stay stay stay
No
That's fucking amazing
No, she beat me. You whore. Are you serious? Stay stay stay
She beat me by one point because of that hole in one. Are you
bro
You're American not here, please. It's all I'm throwing it. I'm also Scottish. It's also for Scotland. Let's go
You better be Scottish
Everyone drink water. I drink water. I'm sorry, I drink water. Water, but I have game yourself. Is that okay?
It's all the only water you need. Use code Mersey for 10% off. Let them know. Use code Mersey for 10% off Gamer subs. Let them know
Use code Azara. Use code Sheeby. Use code IC. Use code Amy. Use code Sorry. I'd rather you use the girls' codes than my codes
So use one of their codes instead
Let's go
I didn't get a prize. So rude
No consolation prize exactly. No, I got third place
And I didn't even get a medal or a prize or even or even like an achievement. You can have a cookie. I didn't get anything either
I came in first with the participation
participation award
Yeah, you get a participation award trophy to ground my enemies with
What the hell
How do I come in first and then not get anything?
Oh wait, I could be sushi a whole in one
I want to be your whole in one
I'm gonna be your whore in one. Are you?
I want to be the whole please and thank you
This is a border
Oh
I did not help at all. I thought I was gonna help you mercy not gonna lie
I like being
Give me a moment. I need to rethink that one
Oh, honestly, I'm like that. I'm like I need to recalibrate the joke. Give me a second. Hold on
Damn, I'm like, there's a joke here somewhere. Just give me a second to get through it. That's all I need. I just need a moment
A zero with the whole in one
No way. We're getting through this. Oh, it's all about time and all and
Oh, come on. Thank you. Sorry. I'm on a lily pad. How pretty
I'm not too hard but hard enough to make it through. Oh, yeah, not too hard but hard enough to make you come
Oh
Give me that part. Oh, no, it'll be a boogie
Well, Lemmy's now in my way, so
Can I get a sanity check on our polar bear, I would like a sanity check on
What was the name? What was the name? Groomed by a groomed by healer
Uh, are we all allowed to say that? Are we gonna? Oh
No, I for groom doesn't like, you know, like, uh, like, you know
What about grooming? Like, like, like, you know, brushing your hair. Yeah
Yeah, you want an ASMR rule play? Sure
I've got plenty of grooming to go around. I don't know. I mean, I got five birdies
I'm in the water
AC is your make-on or am I getting nervous that you're deadly silent because you're about to like go feral
I see. Let's go
Silence from Mercy is scary. Monka is. I'm getting
F***ing from AC's worst because she's feral polar bear. She's learning how it began back in civilization again
Oh, I don't know how to make this. Oh, I'm getting nervous. I'm getting shaky. I see
I see. Can you hear me? No, we can. Oh, you know
I was talking. I was talking. I don't know why I couldn't hear me on discord. What the f***
I was talking. What the f***? I was worried you were like serious. What did you say?
I was literally still like raging in a
It was awfully quiet without your raging
Exactly where am I
This is gonna be a a headache in a hassle unless unless
No
What the f***
Okay, walk in walk in. It was the picture on twitter with keyboard broken real
I'm so rude
Hey, I see
Even though I'm lazy, why'd you go that way? Oh, it's the wrong way
F*** i'm f***ing stupid
You know, it's like me. I hate video games and I hate
Hate golf and I hate
You're becoming a hater
Maybe I always was a hater
I was not too good, bro. It's not too good. Oh, no, no
I see land in the
I see
Yeah
Kind of in the middle of of that little bridge in the middle of this bridge
How to go for that wall?
Upwards no, she's gonna stroke out
Try aiming for the wall
Just a little just a little yeah, there you go
Oh
Baby
Sorry, I almost got a hole in one. Wait, it looks like stroney went in the hole. Um, oh, uh, please
I did a rimshot. You know what I'm saying?
You were saying
Thank you very much. It wasn't necessary the end at the end of that was brother
Here I am
No
All right, here we go almost f***
Oh, she's dying we need to resurrect
I
Someone gift an emergency
Thank god. Oh, thank f***ing god. Let's go
I almost got a hole in one on that one. God damn it. I hate video game and I hate golf and I hate
Pro golfer Tiger Woods y'all Tiger Tiger Woods y'all
Yeah
Does anyone know any names of any other golfers other than Tiger? I don't watch golf
OJ Simpson the one like wait no
Wait, didn't see OJ
I don't know. You just say OJ Simpson. Yeah, I don't think he's
No, he was a football player that murdered his wife. Yeah
There you go. That's what he is
Whoopsies my apologies
Sorry, I don't know
I'm dead
I don't know American things. Okay. I tried my best. I wanted to name one of their golfers. You tried. That's okay
You tried, uh, I know fictional golfers like, uh,
Padna, golf, hang out
Fictional golfers won't go flying off the end of the map. There's no end on fictional golfers
Oh careful, you know like in the anime and video games
Oh, all right, that makes sense. That makes sense. Oh, I'm just like
No, I'm getting edged by a hill
Oh, baby
No, triple. Oh, baby. You baby a double. Oh, baby
Oh
Thank you
You
I'm here
I'll actually rolled in our POV. Whoa, bam
Oh
You're right. I can't believe it. Is there a just trickshot that
I don't know if I'd believe it
All right, yeah, I was too soft
We'll get hard. No, you gotta be done
Are you sprinkling salt on your bowl?
Hey guys, did you know that if you dip your balls in soy sauce, you can taste it?
You should probably do that right now.
I had my viewers do it. They said it wasn't true. No, we're supposed to you're supposed to tea
You've earned it. They well, sorry if they've already done it for me. I already got many videos of them dipping their balls
Yeah, it was pretty nice and somebody dipped it in syrup too. It's pretty cool
That's sticky
That's when you know, he's canadian pops that stuff and maple syrup
I don't know what the canadian
Like theme song is oh no, that's not what they're called. Sorry
Oh
You're supposed to have video of the person dipping their toes in the peanut butter
Yeah, someone was licking it off
I mean, I thought if one of you guys dipped your toes in peanut bar
Because
Don't mind me. Don't mind. Oh, for goodness sake. I love peanut butter
Me too. I didn't realize it was a really good one. I like smooth peanut butter personally
Oh, i'm a crunchy peanut butter and banana on top. I don't like peanut butter
Wow dropped
I can only I can only eat real peanuts if it's if it's like made out of like
Peanut butter that's like a hundred percent just peanuts. Yeah fucking shit. Yeah, that's the only one I can eat
Stroni's on my arse. I'm cumin. I'm cumin. You need to keep
I couldn't hear a little
What did you just say?
What did you say?
I didn't hear
Her chat chat
No, they're all talking about peanut butter. They said oh someone said all of a sudden i'm a dog
What the
Someone hit you
Oh, there we go. Yes, you did it. I'm shitting me. Okay now it's just in service. I thought I wanted to suck your whole fucking day
Oh, we love hearts coming off me. Oh, i'm able to sew this. Stroni is straddling me right now
We're on the same number. Okay, we must how do we distract?
How do we distract her um, I'm gonna need some help right now. How did how did she get distracted by?
uh
Slime
Slime girl. Slime girl. Slime girl. Slime girl. Slime girl. Slime girl.
I hate slime girls. Oh my god. The invert manifolds in anger. I want to be a slime girl. I hate slime girl
I'm so angry about slime girls grrr
Slime girls
Hear him hear them you're gonna have to help me out
We have to stop her
Yeah, that's right. I'm a threat
Oh
We're getting corraled like animals don't you see the game has us pitched against each other
Through the power of friendship and love
In the words of I see
Oh my god, I'm gonna fart
Oh
No, oh dear she be am I getting on
The tea in the harbor
I was watching it as the Americans revolted against the taxes against you
Right someone else give me American history come on
Oh
Speaking in their acts their actual accent. Oh, I don't think anyone would understand me for start
Anybody wants to hear my new England accent
Go for it
This is my
Yeah, hold on hold on she's like to do it before anyone starts
Weird
There's an ASMR idea to well not really ASMR because it was like really aggressive and it would be a lot of yelling
Yeah, we're going to the don't anybody want anything from Donk's kid. Yeah, yeah, you're fucking stupid from
Before anyone starts accusing that was not me for what that was my brother
That was Amy's burp. Yeah, I was a really good burp. That was a very good burp. Oh fuck. This is hard
Oh, thank you for lining me up though. I see hold on. Let me go
Who just banked me
Right now
Nobody's chaotic right now.
Walking go.
Oh, it's her.
Yeah.
Azzara go.
I got a pocket.
Oh my god.
Give me one.
It's your turn.
Oh, there you go.
No way you took the kill!
Oh, my God.
Gracefully.
No way!
Do you just get knocked in?
What, you just went in for me and then you jumped out.
The ping is the ping.
Yo, why did he cancel your neck?
Oh, I'm winning, I'm still winning, there's a chance, so you're saying there's a chance.
So you're saying there's a chance.
I'm gonna lose.
Just time me out already, kill me.
Thank you.
Call fit the game is pain personify.
It is.
All right, how am I, okay, how are we supposed to get there?
I heard I'm so sorry whoever went in the water, but I heard the SFX so clearly it was like
strong.
I'm so sorry.
You better go.
I have.
I have, but I keep moving someone hit me and I keep moving away.
I need to.
No, I was so close.
Shit.
Albatross.
Damn.
I can't.
Oh, that's a great song.
I'm so sorry.
Real gamer blames the pangs.
Exactly.
My pain is astronomical.
Look at that.
It's gonna be so fucking hard.
This blade.
I hate this.
Bro, if I hit someone in there, I'm gonna be so pissed.
The war physics in this game.
I have to compliment him.
It's beautiful.
You're going to war.
Someone named CPS just tip me in talking about how I killed my Tamagotchi.
Oh, no, he hasn't forgiven you for your friends against your Tamagotchi.
I've killed many a Tamagotchi.
Wait, I might just choke out for this.
Oh, man.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Yes.
Five.
So much for us.
Five hundred dollars.
Holy shit.
Thank you.
Let's fucking go.
Garbuckle.
Thank you, Mr. G. More like, more like bang, funk, more like bang, funk, I don't fucking
know.
Well, first place is we meet up with you.
What's the art?
Wait, just trying to get in.
Oh, I'm fucked.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
I got in long ago.
Check out the scoreboard.
Press shift and see how many it took me to do.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Fuck him.
Shit in me right now.
Okay.
I mean, my ancestors proud.
I can mess up everything after this.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
I got the most.
I'm close to Rika.
I unlocked a literal job.
Oh, shit.
I'm mercy.
Mercy jumping.
Mercy, why do you keep clicking quit?
Because I'm stupid.
I was also too excited.
Maybe I don't know.
I miss so many.
You.
Close your eyes.
Go to bed, something, something in your head.
Dream dream dream dream.
I'm really feeling it are you feeling it now mr. Mercy should I do
What should I do should I do hard mode?
Yeah, yes, you there's one
And then we'll end on this one because we've almost
If I think one more game is gonna take us like 30 minutes and then is or can get on with her business
Cuz she's got a little thing
Grimmed by veal or I guess strengths again
Gonna kill I see with hard mode
I'm sorry. I see for what I'm about to do
Click ready model be lagging
I can't wait. Oh, sorry. I forgot to hit ready. I was waiting for you
Big ass fucking carrots, we're on the farm reef lens
Sorry Pete. I have a milk and farm
Oh
This is a weird J temple. There's turnips on the floor. What's with the random bar at the bottom that was
No, I radishes
How do you get on the thingie strutty strutty don't do it strutty. I'm not gonna do it a kiss
We are I think we're touching. Oh, no, we're not touching sorry for my work. We're very close to touching tips
Oh
Damn, oh my gosh, I couldn't be honest. Please. This is anyone's win because of how awkward this map is
This is literally anyone's win. It's my
Why do I keep on getting back one of y'all?
Yes, yes, yes, yes
Yes, you know what this is the last game I choose violence
Oh
Why am I in such a bad spot
Let me let me move first. Okay. I will I will
I'm losing brain
I'm still at the fucking beginning
Hi, oh, yeah, thank you. Look man. Oh my god. We're back in the fucking building
Hershey beat
I'm going I'm going for you. There's like a pat you go four seconds to plot three seconds. It's fine. I'm still moving
Can I it doesn't matter?
We're supposed to go to that island all the way over there
All the war you can skim across it like a
Oh, but you're not supposed to go inside the water. Oops
Like you can't land in the water
You have an enemy. It's me. I've chosen violence. I will be destroying all of you
Monka everyone stay away from she be literally
No, why am I in water but not that was weird
Okay, I might have to do a trick shot for that
I'm safe. I'm safe in the hole. I think just kidding. I see decided which way am I supposed to go?
Um forward forward over the bridge. You're going violence. I am too
No, there's two
Actors in the game
Be safe be safe my daughter. Where am I? Oh shit
Wait, I have an idea
Okay, I got in oh wait, I'm actually really close. I'm really close. Hold on. Hold on. I keep on hitting that like a one
Come on. Come on. Come on. I'm gonna hit. Come on
Damn
Thank you so much for the $50
I'm coming for you
I'm coming for you. I bounced out. Fuck me
Okay
Come on. She you got this
Easy hole in one. Watch this. Watch this easy hole in one easy hole in one easy easy easy
I'll throw it in so whoever second police can win. How about that? No, no, no, no
I'm gonna kick you out. That's what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna fart in your eyelashes
Don't give me pink eye. I don't need that
Uh, sure you have the cleanest arsehole in all the land
There's me pink
I don't know you got to ask like in fart strontis. So you probably will give me pink
Damn girl you go you fart with that ass. Yeah, I guess
She was the drunk. Yeah, that's the two day suspension, right? I'm making up the
I'm making up the lie right now. Um, uh, she'd be
unfortunately, um
Oh
I had a family matter to tend to oh, unfortunately, she's offline for 40 hours. Don't worry. I'm putting up the white page in black
text as I speak
I'm so sorry for what I must do. Oh, you're lucky. We are so sorry to report
That it were precious talent
I can't do this
I'm losing my mind. Sorry for choosing high and bad
Oh, hey, mercy. What's up? Okay. Um, I love you
I love hey, um, I love you
Oh
Oh, you know you're not over there. You're not through in the game. You're just kissing with your walls
You're just touching balls
Like your womb walls, I don't know
Call me an IUD because I'm about to insert myself
Oh
My love tabs
Oh, whoa, this looks fun. Actually I kind of I kind of scouted ahead
I almost took the advantage there
What about me to me? What I am
Oh
What I just hit an invisible wall
Oh my god, those are like those soba noodles in japan where you the noodles come down and shoot a war
That's why I said it looked fun
At a door when you guys just watch accent, I just love it. I'm like
I actually didn't that time I didn't go after you
Ken where Ken where Ken actual work that's it. I've had enough
Oh my god
The easiest right, I'll give you a sentence and you'll have to mimic it. Okay. Okay
Okay, so to say you're gonna come to my house. You would say my bit. So what the sentence is
I can I can't wait for you to come to my bit
To come to my bit
Let's map it means my house
Literally m a and then b i t is my house
How much money to have you motivate me to finish cleaning my house of what?
Free free
I see how about you chose a sentence and yours
Everyone
Oh, no
Moshi moshi
I can't believe you've done this
I hit you let's fucking go from who from who
Excellent
Axel rod, thank you for you're getting a golf clap axel rod. I think that's what I'm gonna go club in the head
We're actually just clapping you into mp3 sorry
No, no, I need to go to a little to the right. Literally. It's too dangerous
Oopsy daisy, where the fuck is the hole?
It's
I can't go straight. I can only go gay. That was like
Oh, just the name I did it. Oh, here's another freeze for you
The fucking trees on fire after this game
Look at this. He is cb's edging. I'm edging. Why do I keep edging? I'm not supposed to be the one who edges
Why are we screaming
Why are you guys saying penalized penalized
Oh my god, we're literally
I'm falling into the ether
Oh my god, this bridge is like matt. Oh, it keeps me going. Oh the bridge is like a conveyor belt
Oh
It's a conveyor belt. Yeah, like it takes you all the way across make sure you aim for the middle
I kid you not aim for the middle or it's gonna keep your trajectory
And tara sante shit. Oh, I see I see
Time to ruin it
Oh
You're too late to the
You snooze you
I'm getting complete I'm gonna cry. I'm gonna
You're gonna share that peepee with the rest of us
Yeah
Do you have enough to share with the class because
I never learned to pronounce their names, so I named them peepee. That's cute
I don't know how I actually managed to just got renamed by zura. I see I was I'm gonna start calling you everybody different names now
Oh, yeah, that's me. There you go. Perfect flawless imagine she gets in. Oh god damn it
Why is there carrots? I don't know because you know
No
Oh my god, we're getting carried by the river. This is so cute. Yeah
I'm so sorry if I hit someone
I hit the birthday girl look a little bit
Be mindful of the current
No, no, no, no, no
Okay, we made it we made lazy live or
Fuck my life
Uh
my head in my head.
No way.
How did I do that?
I'm going to cry.
Fuck.
Did you almost hit me?
Why does the current take you around the hole?
I don't.
Around the outside.
No.
Guess who's back?
Who's dying?
Me.
I'm back again.
Mercy's dying.
Tell him, friend.
I'm telepathy.
Wait, hold on.
Mercy's dying.
Come on.
For those of you who are loving women.
I'm going to kill myself in Minecraft.
Now hold on a minute.
That's why you got hired.
Alright.
Now for anyone who's like,
what on earth is the context of that?
I may or may not have been chosen
for her same amount of words
that she used against someone
that was rather inappropriate for most agencies.
But you know,
you know what we do a little bit differently here.
What the heck is that?
What the fuck is up, Kyle?
Do it.
What?
Now step the fuck up, Kyle.
Oh shit.
I might never.
Oh no.
What the fuck pushed me?
Where am I?
Mercy's coming for blood.
She's bringing me all the way to the beginning.
About to murder.
Wait, how are we supposed to get past the lantern?
You got to jump it.
You got to X games.
Oh, you don't X game mode.
I made it.
This is far away.
I didn't mean to hit.
Look at this.
Can I please?
Oh my god.
I'm on a date.
I'm a bee.
Oh shit.
No, please.
This is not what I wanted.
Mercy dying in the background.
Is that Xeris Mike Fixenert?
I think it is.
Mike Fixenert.
You take that filler off right now.
I'm going to fart on it.
I don't want to hear anything.
You always start into farts.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
You think you use this shit?
You ain't even a fart.
I'll be going home.
Fucking fine.
I don't know.
I'll keep it a stack.
There we go.
A stack.
Oh my god.
I'm going to make a mess.
Sudoku.
Mercy ran out of time.
I'm not last place.
Let's go.
Big W today.
Oh sorry.
Is that...
I was losing it.
Oh it is you.
Mercy said Sudoku.
Excuse me.
What is that?
Have I gone the wrong way?
No I think you're in the right spot.
We're supposed to hit that really hard I think.
Oh come on.
Are we supposed to hit that target?
Where'd my hand go?
I'll tell you.
Holy shit.
Don't fuck me.
What the fuck?
Sorry is there a...
Wee.
Guys where am I and how am I supposed to get there?
I just fell off the face of the earth.
This horse?
I'm still falling.
Where's the target?
Where's the hole?
Is it the fucking...
The blue...
The grill?
It's the grill.
It's the golden pot of blue supper.
It's like in between...
Do you see the...
Oh my gosh.
I think it's almost 100.
Yeah it's the pot.
Oh it's the pot.
Oh it is the pot.
That's weird.
Oh my god.
It's the cauldron looking thing.
The cauldron? That's burner?
Yeah I'm sure it has an actual name
but I have no idea what to call it.
I actually know what the function is.
No I ran out of time.
Holy shit.
I forgot to use the other way again.
I'm not the last place.
That's crazy.
Why appreciate it being here?
You need to pick a game that you're good at.
We can like roll out.
It's so over.
I don't know if we told you.
When we first met, we played
that party game.
What is it called?
Jackbox?
Jackbox.
And through Ace of Cull was lost again
and I felt so bad.
No more PTSD
from being last place in the fucking game.
And it wasn't fair
because the questions were like
English questions and they're really awkward.
Words that's not everyday vocabulary.
So it was like
what is the plural of this word?
What is a baby of this animal
called? And it was like
this is one fair on Ace.
English isn't her first language.
It's okay. I just have low IQ
with spine.
It makes me
correct.
You're not dumb sorry.
He's not dying.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ray Kumar.
Thank you Mr. Ray Kumar.
Any Ray Kumar?
Any Ray Kumar's in here?
Any Ray's in here?
Ray.
Oh my god.
You really are fucking higher
in the delivery truck. What the fuck?
Oh my god the next girl is the Peeler
allegation.
Wait what's the Peeler allegation?
The four of you
need or may not have
peed on microphone.
Azura hasn't and I'm next
after her. I said
Azura finishes it.
I have to, I will finish it.
Wait what?
I have to look at her because we've all
peed.
Lemonade into the toilet.
Yeah, yeah. Lemonade.
We made lemonade.
Yes.
I don't know.
Azura's channel.
Fuck.
I've had worse things on my own channel.
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
Why is it looking like shit everywhere?
And what the fuck is the rocks?
80 need, M.A. need,
TB need and Mercy need.
So Azura need is next, and then
Strongly need. Strongly need just sounds like
a grenade to me honestly.
Strongly need.
I'm just slew.
Don't mind me.
Cheeky Willie Pete over here.
You gotta hit the middle of the center.
I literally cannot get on this.
Oh, I did it.
I'm gonna go fall out.
I can't seem to find the common.
Let's go.
Is everyone struggling to get on this spot?
It's just you.
It's too hard.
In what? Tabernac.
There, I said it. Tabernac.
Tabernac?
We're going to the temple?
I hate this.
French Quebec is like
Tabernac.
Hey, where's the whole...
Where did you get it from?
Oh, no, I finished it.
Cool.
That's the whole...
I'm punishing Imi and Mrici.
Whenever Imi and Mrici misbehave,
I punish them with French,
but not just any kind of French,
Scottish accent.
Tabernac.
Oh, Jean-Thuy.
It'll be blue.
Come stay, come sa.
Oui.
Other French, I know.
Oh, Montere.
There's no physics, there's no like
Chatterpool on this damn stupid...
Oh, je voudrais
une peeler allocation.
Je voudrais
Je voudrais une peeler allocation.
I would like a pill.
This is a real punishment.
Suspension isn't punishment around these parts.
Not sure, this is a real punishment.
Pillar again.
We need...
Not my internet.
Oh, no, she's giving out...
I heard her voice like...
Help!
I'm helping you, Mercy.
I love you.
I'm trying.
Great, okay, let me...
Oh, what?
I see.
You sound like a character
from in any Sims game.
Do a Scottish accent on a different language?
I don't know.
She sounds cute.
What are we saying?
Is this similar?
Why are you doing this?
If you get stuck,
you're supposed to hold R?
Yeah.
Did we stop the entire time?
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
You're stuck.
Please.
I'm sorry.
Oh, please.
Please, for the love of God.
Oh, no.
You're supposed to hold 25 dollars.
I'm not a fan.
You're supposed to hold 10 dollars.
I'm supposed to go.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
I want to go this way just because...
You're supposed to hold...
You can't go that way.
You can't get to know that we can't go that way.
You cannot go that way.
I'm sorry.
I need to be sent to the asylum after this.
I like how Mercy is freaking bad.
Oh, my God.
AC had a story that came out,
and it was her missing in a word,
and it got so many views.
Oh, yeah, I saw it.
It got so many views, and I was like, damn AC,
keep messing up your English.
Okay, let's go.
No, my internet.
Please, my internet.
This is the best I've done.
Oh, no.
What?
Is this an asylum?
It's not asylum.
It's asylum for it.
Asylum?
It's asylum.
Asylum.
Yes, asylum.
Carnival.
It was such, it did so well.
I was like, fuck you.
I keep messing up your English
while farming so hard.
No.
Oh, right. Don't do it too hard.
Don't do it too hard up there.
Too late.
Oh, and I did it too gentle naturally.
You know.
Whoopsies.
You got to hit it just right.
I'm dying.
Are you in game?
Are you still in game?
I'm still in game.
My internet just keeps cutting out.
The game is, the internet is like,
I know what's important here.
Make sure she can continue playing the game.
Literally.
What's the fun?
Okay, there are bridges to go down,
so you don't need to whack too hard
to get to the bottom.
I like to whack hard.
Yeah, on my way.
Hey!
What the hell?
It looks like, no.
It's like, Amy had picked up Strani's ball.
On my screen from the left.
They're taking me away.
I had enough of me being in game.
I'm kidding. I love you.
I love you all, even though I hate the golf.
Okay, I will do the same exact reaction
in Golf with Friends.
Come on.
Nice.
Hold on.
Okay, bye.
We did it.
Oh, we got to go up.
Yeah, you go.
Thank you.
Oh, I made it.
No, I didn't.
Fuck my life.
Damn it.
Oh, not bad.
Oh, please.
Oh, my God, please.
Okay, no.
This is possible.
You tapped for this.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, don't mind if I do.
Don't mind if I do.
Let's get on the cam.
Let's see what's happening with the dogs.
What are we, Five Nights at Freddy's character?
I'm fucking up the...
No.
I'm getting the action replay.
What are you supposed to do?
Oh, my fuck.
Keep going that way.
Are you serious, bro?
I want to...
I want to commit to Dooku and cry.
Isn't that so Dooku?
Yeah.
I think it's Dooku.
It's Sapuku.
Yeah, I know.
That's the meme.
I didn't even know what it was.
I'm going to commit to Dooku.
Dooku is a number game.
Yeah, I know.
Yes, yes, yes.
It's my favorite game. I like the game.
I'm really good at it.
I'm great at Sapuku, though.
What? Whoa.
Hold on a minute.
I'm going to commit to Dooku.
Ten seconds.
I'm just kidding.
It doesn't matter.
Do I sneeze?
True.
This will be my last trailer.
I'm going to commit to Dooku.
Could you...
Oh, well, it brings a lot of publicity.
I'm teasing.
You know what? Just for you, scrawny.
No, I'm teasing.
For anyone who takes that seriously.
Relax.
For the views?
No, that's terrible.
I'm doing it for the vine.
I'm going to do it for the vine.
Where are we supposed to go?
Oh, that way.
You can't hit the gong.
That's so rude.
Oh, no, make sure you do it.
Oh, right. No, it's fine.
Oh, my God, I thought I didn't do it hard enough.
You go in.
That was amazing. I just saw that.
I'm so sorry.
Damn it.
I'm sorry. My ping is better than yours.
That's pretty accurate.
What is my ping?
What does it say?
Yes!
The best I ever did.
That was a great trick shot.
Oh, my God, Sakura.
Kawaii-nee, Sakura-no.
Well...
I think my favorite is Ronnie
just being really...
really bad Japanese.
I think I used to be able to say...
Well, actually, right?
This is really terrible, Lord.
I can only say sentences from hentai,
stuff like all that feels good
in Japanese and like...
It was an example.
It was an example?
Yeah, we need a taste.
It's like taste test.
Come on.
Oh, my God!
What the fuck is that?
That's me.
What do you mean by that?
It sounds like you at all.
It doesn't feel good.
Come here.
Oh, my God.
Wait, listen.
I just had like a terrible thing
pop in my head.
Should I say it?
Say it here.
I was like...
Imagine
off-collab taste
test stream where I just taste
everyone's vagina.
Oh, my God!
Look.
I can hear you.
Taste a stream
with my girls.
Oh, my God.
Turn out of test.
That'd be a great stream.
Oh, my God.
Oh, man.
I'm speechless.
No, because I can't...
I didn't know she was going to say that.
Oh, my God.
I'm down for anything, but...
What the fuck?
I'll be buying everyone yogurt
and hydrating for no particular reason.
I'll have some pineapple.
I'm not going to argue.
Oh, well, Mercy's sweet.
I want to taste.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Oh, sweet.
Surprise.
Are you kidding me?
How did you guys get up the stairs?
The stairs take you up.
Yeah.
But how? I can't.
Wait, there you go.
Oh, no, she's rolling down the stairs.
She's dead.
Why?
They hit and patrolled,
and they tried to catch me right in cocky...
They hit and...
Oh, I'm not last play.
Trying to catch me right in cocky...
Oh, shit.
I could have gotten that.
This is like Harry Potter.
Oh, shit.
Can I, like, just fall down into this one?
one. Where are we? Please, please, please. Oh, come on. Where do we go? What the fuck do we go now?
Okay, finally, I got it. I got it. I got it. Oh, okay. Where the fuck? It's on the floor.
That's the old hole, isn't it? Is it? So where's Spook? Oh, yes, 17. We're on for eight. I can't
even find it, so I'm looking around. Where are they? I don't know where to go. Oh, I see it down.
No, that's the... It's on the ceiling. It's on the ceiling.
On the ceiling? Oh, yeah. Oh, it is. What the hell? You don't have to tell me twice.
What the fuck about the ceiling? Why can't I just go all the way down here? I can't see anything, though.
Just eat it. That's such bullshit. The hole is literally down there. No, it's on the ceiling.
The old one. That's the old one. Oh, they're sitting on the wall. I'm fucking stupid. Never mind.
I really thought I found out an amazing way to get it. I already tried that way.
I can't fucking see shit. I'm not gonna lie. Gravity changes. If you look around,
gravity changes when you go up. But how do you...? I don't know how to get up there. I'm sorry.
I'm on the wall. I'm on the wall, but I don't know how to get up to the wall.
Maryse, do you see where Shabia is? You need to go on that side and then eat yourself up with them.
Oh, I see it. Yes, perfect. Eating.
Well, I'm on the wall. What the fuck? Where am I?
You're... You're... Oh, let's go. So good. Oh, we love it. Bye-bye.
No, there's only one second. No, I wanted to do it. It looks fun. I wanted to finish.
I was so close. Oh, my God. I got a plunger. I got a Joby again.
You got another shit? I got the plunger. You got the shit, so...
I got a pink hat. So who's got the fart?
I love when they do that in rap, where they just go,
country boy, I love you.
Here. Right. I am going to say a grand spank and thank you for everyone for showing up for
Azir's Dornathon and we got to have Vila praying together. I'm happy to see that no,
there will not be a white text and black font coming out anything soon.
I'm getting... I'm getting terminated, guys.
Yeah, it's just great. It's great termination. I'm going to have someone skin walk with Chibi.
Just warning, you know. I'm teasing. I'm teasing.
I just come back next week with a different voice.
Literally. I'm like, actually, nothing's different. Really, what are you talking about?
This guy's like... Oh, my God. This was the 250 anonymous.
Thank you. Anonymous. Anonymous. Anonymous. Anonymous. Anonymous.
Thank you. I missed out. Anonymous.
What is the agendination is myself and the other girlies are going to all redirect into
Azir's Dornathon. You all be forced to sit and watch. Azir has put so many plans into today's
show. Please do. Even if you want to lurk in the shadows, you're more than welcome to.
Yeah, definitely support Azirah today.
Wait, where the fuck am I?
On the main menu.
Like close to my YouTube studio, like a dumbass.
What the actual fuck?
We all get redirected to Azirah and you're going to kiss her.
And there are some...
Can you read around it?
Yes, there are some girls that are doing streams, but after their streams,
anyway, they're going straight back into Azirah. So please don't worry.
Okay, thank you so much everyone. I'm going to jump out of voice chat and wrap up my stream real
quick. But thank you so much for playing. I was so hurt in a hauler.
I had a lot of fun.
Okay.
Excuse me.
Hi.
Wait a minute. Can you hear me?
I'm tired.
I'm not used to streaming this early in the morning. It's not even morning anymore.
It's afternoon.
It's also hot as balls.
But we're going to read into Azirah's stream. Let me just...
Well, I don't know if it'll work because lately,
lately raids haven't been working on YouTube.
So I will also put the link for you.
But thank you so much for coming.
Even though it's 2 a.m. for you.
Oh, damn. Thank you for watching.
So late at night.
You're going to take a nap before the next stream?
No. I have some recording to do, so I won't be able to.
But I will take a break. At least I'll try.
If I don't find myself, you know, procrastinating the whole time while recording, then...
I will try to take a break.
Azirah's already at 8000? Oh, I'm so happy for her.
I really hope she gets to move out.
She really deserves to.
She really, she really, she really, you know...
I don't know how to say it. I'm like...
Stupid brain drain. Let me frog blink.
I can't even frog blink on purpose.
Okay, whatever.
I will copy and paste the link.
Okay, I'll see you later today.
4 hours. I did have to calculate that. That's embarrassing.
I'll see you in 4 hours. Okay. Bye-bye, Pookie.